I fell for this very nice invitation I
see that the audience is very diverse so
let me start by asking a question just
to be sure who all know what
so can you raise your hands how many of
you have heard of this company called
Google last time I asked this question
somebody on in the audience said when I
get home I'll Google for it okay
so so here we go
so the two big achievements of Google
are that were that they gave us a way of
doing search that is robust to spam
using their great idea of PageRank and
they gave us and there is they
completely revolutionized advertising
and that forms their business model
because of which they can bring us
search for free 24/7 so and and if you
type say Vioxx I will as a keyword then
here you get the results that are
relevant to it as search results and
here you get advertisements that are
given by by companies to be put right
next to this word this keyword why ox
and similarly advertisers have given
provided you know ads to be shown with
all the other keywords and there are so
many of them because it's not just one
word it could be multiple words anyway
so the revolution is the following that
google managed to solve the most central
problem in advertising namely how to
match merchants to customers who want
their products okay in a very targeted
way and the difficulty of course in
doing this matching is how to find out
exactly what the needs and desires of a
customer are I mean you can put a
thousand and thousand make every
see your your ad you know by putting it
on a billboard but that's such a waste
not everybody is going to buy that car
if you could target it to the specific
people who want the car
won't that be much more efficient and
and and their big insight was that our
users search query is really a suction
window into the mind and the needs of a
user that's what the user is thinking
about at this moment whatever they are
searching about and so why not give ads
related to this search query and the
solution is now to auction off the
queried keywords to advertisers so that
they bid for keywords and Google makes
some money on the side as well and this
converts a giant undefined matching
problem of matching customers to
businesses into a gigantic auction and
indeed Google is the world's biggest
auction house today auctioning off
billions of keywords every day and this
has not only brought us search for free
has revolutionized our lives because we
keep using Google all the time
but it has also led to huge profits for
Google which went from being a twenty
seven billion dollar company in 2004 to
more than a trillion dollars today so
that's all based on this one market can
you believe it the AdWords market which
is ephemeral and non-existence in
non-existent in in real atoms and and
blood right it's digital completely so
that's the new new error that we are
living in today so the big question is
how do does google allocate keywords to
advertisers and the what happens is that
abroad Wiser's bid for specific keywords
such as Vioxx or pizza or or maid
service or or honda core and then
Google displays the ad of the highest
bidder and that is good from the
economic point of view because that's an
efficient solution according to
economics whoever can make them make the
most value out of that particular ad
being there gets that ad and that value
is demonstrated by the amount of money
they are willing to spend and that way
the whole economy benefits the most and
of course it also maximizes Google
Google's revenue okay so so so this is
there this was their basic solution
namely display the ad of the highest
bidder
so for now just for this talk let's
assume that Google will display only one
ad even though you saw many ads
displayed just for simplicity and then
Google can either charge the bit or the
second highest bid just like a Vickery
option to make it incentive compatible
and the people don't go around fishing
around for the right bidding bid to to
put in so that they are out there and
this solution was being used for the
first couple of years from 2002 to 2004
or so and then they realized that there
was a oh and here it is these are the
ads so normally this is considered the
most important position so this is where
the highest bidder goes the second
highest bidder and so on and typically
he pays the the amount that this guy has
bid he pays the amount that this guy has
been and so on and what would you have
expected here pharmaceutical companies
that are willing to pay 10 or 20 cents
to be here but instant what you see is
lawyers lawyers lawyers lawyers lawyers
because they are happy to pay 50 to 100
dollars to be here because Google at
some point managed to hurt a lot of
people through their absolutely
why acts managed to hurt a lot of people
through their through their drugs and
these people want to recoup some of that
money through
through lawsuits and of course so what
happens is that if a user who clicked
Vioxx clicks on this ad then the amount
of money maybe the bit of this guy goes
from this lawyers account to Google's
account and that's how Google makes its
revenue yeah there's a trademark term so
it's use that does this pair use govern
the use of how key word relates to
lankman language and the intention I so
as I said you know keyword if there are
more keywords than there are words and
an even multiple words form a keyword
you can say pepperoni pizza you can say
women's clogs okay that's not one word
so I I don't know what their definition
of keyword is but it's anything that you
type is is a keyword into Google search
box for me for me that definition I'm
not into that research topic so yeah
it's a string yeah so okay so that
that's how Google makes its revenue okay
and that's how makes billions and
billions every quarter
believe it or not okay so but there's a
problem with this way of selling the ads
and namely just the highest bidder gets
it and this was realized around 2004 and
we became aware of this question at the
at that point the point is that when I
user
when when a business creates an ad group
and says what their keywords are and how
much they are willing to bid for each
keyword they also give their daily
budget how much they are willing to
spend in a day so that you know they
don't get bankrupt in one day's
allocation of ads probably okay at least
the small businesses are well aware of
this
issue maybe the big businesses don't
care the more ads they get there the
better okay but there are lots and lots
and lots and lots of small businesses
that go onto Google because they never
had any outlet before Google to
advertise their products okay so so what
happens as a result of this daily budget
and if you still give the ads to the
highest bidder what goes wrong so let's
see this through this example where
there are two bidders one is bidding $1
for the query book and CD and $1 for the
query CD and this Bureau - who's bidding
$0.99 for book and nothing for CD and
both of them have declared a daily
budget of $100 and suppose on this
particular day a hundred book queries
come first and then 100 CD queries come
just happens to be an ordinary day in
our lives and so let's see what the
greedy algorithm would do so comes a
book query and bitter one gets it
because he's he's paying $1 for this
query and the second bidder only $0.99
and the rest of the 99 queries also go
there and Google makes $100 here and now
comes a query of the kind CD and bitter
one has no money bidder who doesn't want
it goes waste and so to the other 99 so
Google's revenue is only $100 and these
last hundred queries are are wasted on
the other hand if the optimal way to do
this if you knew the future in advance
what queries are going to come today is
that you would give the first hundred
queries to the second bidder and make 99
dollars from that and the second 100
queries of CD to the first bidder who
has bid for CD and and another $100 so
the total would be 199 which is about
twice as much so you're forced to be at
most half the offline optimal okay
and yeah we're here I'm assuming that
you the bidder just pays what they have
been simplicity first okay algorithms
let let's jump into algorithmic ideas
based on a very simple model yeah no
forget fabric of second price for now
all those bells and whistles can be
thrown in later okay so so we must
incorporate budget because we are being
forced into 50% of the revenue and when
the revenue is billions of dollars you
can see how much is being left on the
table so and this is also important
because a very large fraction of the
advertisers are budget constraint the
the budget curve is very heavy tailed
and you want to deal with these guys
these guys never had an outlet no
advertising means before finally are
having and they're it's having an effect
even the maid who needs an extra job
pays Google about $10 to get another
service possible you know the pizza
store in the corner or or or the guy who
sells extra-large shoes or whatever have
you so so so so these have to be
adequately addressed moreover I mean
everything is happening online and in
real time which is the topic of this
workshop and so the solution has to be
very very efficient real time no no no
big heavy solving LPS or anything and
very very simple solution on top of
whatever Google is doing so far okay so
this is the problem that we faced in
2004 and we solved it in 2005 we being
erroneous meta
I mean sub-area animation me and these
two were my students at Georgia Tech at
that time and a redneck is now at Google
I mean at Stanford I'm at our wine so we
are all West Coast based at this point
which is
okay so what we started off with was a
books oh and of course everybody knows
who meshes have been at Berkeley for
thirty years I don't have to announce
that so so what we started off with was
a simple framework that captures the
essential features of the of this
problem so that we can arrive at an
algorithmic solution okay and and we can
add bells and whistles later as I
mentioned to AB dokie so here's a very
very simple problem assume everybody
every bidder has a daily budget of $1
and these advertisers give bids for
keywords that they are interested in
they specify a keyword and the bid
keyword and the bit keyword and a bit
and the their budget is $1 ok and
queries come and they have to be
selected and sent to an advertiser to
maximize Google's revenue that's it
so and we want to use online competitive
analysis obviously which is to compare
the solution of our four algorithm in an
online sense with whatever the best
offline algorithm solution is okay and
we already saw that greedy has a
competitive ratio of 1/2 when when I
showed you the books and see anything
and it can be forced into a half no more
so what's our algorithm to be tough so
any algorithm will achieve a half I mean
sorry this is a trivial algorithm which
achieves a half and no more so what's
our algorithm will use the agents bid
and the fraction of the budget spent at
any moment ok as time goes on and we
have to decide which which agent gets
our next ad we will use their bid and
the fraction of left over but of fent
budget okay and the important thing in
this algorithm is what's the correct
trade-off between these two parameters
so as to get quote unquote an optimal
online algorithm and I will say what
that is so here's our function f of
alpha is 1 minus e to the
1 minus alpha okay so obviously in the
beginning this function is large and as
more and more of your of a bidders
budget is spent it goes down all the way
to zero okay so that's that's the
multiplier so our algorithm is
multiplied the bid of this advertiser
with F this function f of the fraction
of the budget spent okay and give it to
the highest bidder in this sense by
their modified bid okay and that's just
that's it that's the simple algorithm
all you have to keep track of is one
number do one one F function evaluation
and one multiplication so it's very very
lightweight solution and it has a
competitive ratio of 1 minus 1 over e
which is more than 50% it is 63 64
percent something like that but we have
to make a strong assumption that the
bids are very small compared to the
budget the budget like I said before in
that example was $100 the bids were $1
that's what we want something and I
cannot imagine that somebody's bid will
be like half of the budget that means
they'll get two queries and be done so
we can get rid of those people up front
anyway so that's the overwhelming case
anyway and this is a an optimal
competitive algorithm in the sense that
not even a randomized algorithm can beat
this one minus one over e and of course
this is the worst case bound okay it's
also good in practice and moreover it is
as I mentioned earlier it's simple with
a very minimalistic very lightweight
solution and for this reason it had a
huge impact in the market place it was
not only utilized as a as a heuristic
that didn't necessarily use this
function f but basically they use big
people use big scaling not only for ad
options but for display options and
framework that we gave gave an essential
starting point for thinking about many
budget constraint actions for many ad
products yes sir oh that's a very big
question so sorry I am a time constraint
here so let me just do the algorithms
and yeah you are right good question
big answer sorry not necessarily
I don't Google doesn't tell I mean
Google is uh would never tell us that
they are using our paper I have no idea
so I mean these questions are not my
purview here I just want to show the
algorithmics okay okay so the reason it
had this impact was it's very fast as
low on memory no extra communication you
know just what you wanted and it also
gave rise to a huge amount of new work
this paper did they were all through
from 2005 there's even a workshop at
that's held in the San Francisco area
and there are hundreds hundreds no tens
of researchers that have been hired by a
various search engine companies that
work on many many related and general
problems related to this and and these
are all apparently many of them are
implemented used experimented and so on
ok so the point is that this this
solution has its roots in pure theory in
matching theory so let me get to that
that's what I really wanted to convey to
you today since this is a theory talk so
this the underlying ideas come from
online bipartite matching so think of a
bipartite graph where you have girls and
boys and girls and boys and the girls
are sitting out there and the boys come
one at a time
sorry the boys used to be sitting out
there ok the girls are sitting out there
the boys come one at a time and and
right the boys come one at a time and as
soon as the boy comes
we know which girl he can be matched to
and we have to match him right now
within seconds before the next boy comes
match away and then the next boy comes
and we cannot match him because both
these girls are already matched up but
if you had done things better in the
past we could have matched this guy also
okay so we got some matching there's a
better matching but we are working
online we didn't know what's going to
come in the future so there was no way
of getting everything so again any
deterministic algorithm will do at least
a half because any maximal matching is
at least half the maximum matching and
can be forced into a half and this for
this problem we gave a randomized one
minus one over a factor algorithm again
the same bound it comes up a lot in
online algorithms so and the algorithm
is particularly simple namely just
randomly permute these girls once and
for all and then each time a boy comes
match him to the highest available girl
in this order okay and that will give
you 1 minus 1 over a factor and that's
optimal ok so this was in the backdrop
that's why we got so attracted to this
Google problem because in particular
it's a this is a simple case of AdWords
problem where all the budgets are $1 and
the bids are zero or one dollar and
after this game in some sense and even
more relevant work for our purposes
which was due to Kalyan syndrome and
proofs and they deal with the case the
of B matching where there's a an
asymmetry so the girls can match can be
matched only to one story the boys can
be matched only one boy a girl the guys
who are coming can be matched only one
girl but the girl can be matched to be
boys where B is a very very large number
okay and this this is like the AdWords
problem where the bids are B dollars
sorry the budgets are B dollars B being
a very large number
and the bids are either zero or one
either the girl/boy a pair cannot be
paired or they can be paired okay and
here's their algorithm which is very
very simple and interesting so assign
the next query so or the next boy to the
girl who has me who he likes and among
those he likes the one that he has that
has been married the least so far right
or in the reverse as in the google
language as I in the next query to the
bidder who wants this query and has
spent the least so far this is called
balance and it achieves one minus one
over refactor and again this is optimal
against even randomized algorithms this
is a simple deterministic algorithm okay
so let me show you what how balance goes
so income these 100 book queries and
they are equally given to both of them
because they're here both of them are
bid $1 obviously because that's the what
the problem is remember all the bids are
either 0 dollars or one dollar okay and
then comes the CD queries and they are
all go to bidder one who has bid for
them and better two hasn't bid for them
and so the revenue is 1.5 dollars not $1
as in the greedy case so this is 3/4
competitive and in the limit
it's 1 minus 1 over E so so what we did
was we first gave a new proof for
balance and that's what I will show you
and that's my main take-home message
from algorithms today then we modify
this it's a real P based proof we modify
this for for bids in an arbitrary range
0 to 1
so here bids are either either 0 or 1
and here bids are in the in the interval
0 to 1 and then we used obtain the dual
of this to obtain the trade-off function
between bid and fraction of leftover
budget and I will not go into this part
because it's particularly time consuming
but this is a beautiful thing in itself
to see and I think I should be able to
show you in five minutes
which
I certainly have so here's a new proof
of balance again what's balanced incomes
a query bidders have spent some amount
of their money so far look at the bidder
who wants this query and has spent the
least among the bidders who want this
query give it to that guy and for this
analysis let me assume that the bidders
all have a daily budget of $1 and each
bit is 0 its epsilon dollars or $0 right
so opt will be the best offline
algorithm the revenue of the offline
algorithm and balance is the revenue of
this algorithm and the main case is that
opt is n so each of the bidder spends
his entire dollar so let's just look at
that case and see what what is the best
we can do will show that the algorithm
will do at least n times 1 minus 1 over
E and I will prove it to you that the
algorithm balance will do at least n
times 1 minus 1 over e so it's a 1 minus
1 over e factor algorithm ok so the idea
behind the algorithm is to upper bound
the number of bidders who have spent
less so some bidders will spend their
entire dollar some bitters may spend
almost nothing and some intermediate
guys
so you want to upper bound the bidders
who have spent less okay
so how do we upper bound that so assume
that we pick a large integer K and left
s I be the set of bidders who has spent
money in this interval I minus 1 over K
+ 1
I owe work a ok and let si be it didn't
let the cardinality of si bxi
denoted by X I so we must first
constraint X 1 X 1 is people who really
didn't spend right they are really
hurting our the revenue of our algorithm
then we will try to constrain X 2 then
we will try to constrain X 3 and so on
put as much constraint force it to be
small small small so that
our guys are big big big and we show
some bound right okay so this is a s1
they spent well at most one over K this
is s2 they spend at most two over K 3
over K and so on this is the spending of
algorithm and next thing we do is we
partition the revenue of the algorithm
according to in two layers ok and I'll
say this epsilon dollars is in layer I
if at the moment this epsilon dollars
were spent the bidder had money in this
range I minus 1 over K + i / ki okay so
the bidder had money in this range okay
so for instance this is layer 1 this is
all the money that were such that when
it was spent the bidder had money at
most 1 over K this is spent when this
was spent this money the bidder had
money at most 2 over K between 1 over K
+ 2 over K there - and so on
so so now we start writing our LP and
it's not hard so optimum here so s1 is
the guys who end up spending only 100k
right but these queries were also given
to the offline opt and offline opt
managed to allocate all of them right so
when this query came which was all
allocated by opt to somebody here in s1
it must have been allocated because
there is a whole bunch of people well
because because these guys these bidders
who want one this query right
these bidders who want this worry that's
why up manage to allocate it so so the
algorithm also must have allocated this
query but where would it have allocated
it not not to this better because
because it is a this and the algorithm
only went this far so all of these were
allocated somewhere else
so they must be allocated somewhere else
where would it be allocated
well this bidder who wants this query
has spent at most 1 over K so there must
be a competing bidder who has spent at
most 1 over K to whom this query went
and that must have gone into this layer
1
right this query which was which opt
assigned to somebody in s one who has
spent only one over K so far did not go
to a bidder here because there was a
competing bidder who wanted it and has
spent even less so that competing bidder
must be in layer 1 so all of these
queries must go into layer 1 that gives
us our first constraint that so first of
all it's very easy to see that layer 1
is at most n over K because each layer
is equal so layer 1 is at least one at
most 1 over K and the first constraint
says that x1 the number of people in the
set 1 is at most n over K because this
whole money which is x1 must fit into
layer 1 then we go to the second set of
bidders who spend this much in the
second bracket and let their number be
x2 so so think of this as layer so layer
2 is money such that bidders had had
this much and when they spent and what
happens here layer 2 is at most n minus
x1 over K because because this is not in
layer 2 so layered with everything else
n minus x1 over K and the queries in the
in in this part s 1 and s 2 whatever opt
gave here must go into layer 1 or layer
2 by the same logic as before so
therefore X 1 plus X 2 is at most
whatever monies fits into layer 1 and
layer 2 and so on and so in this manner
we get an LP and we solve it and we show
that it is at least n times 1 minus 1
over ki yeah II and basically this is a
very interesting I think rather powerful
algorithm design approximation algorithm
design schema that came up in the
context of of Facility Location problem
in this work with Camille Jane Normandy
and Marcus
I mean in a little couple of years
earlier and it's a family of LPS that
help you give an upper bound on the
approximation factor or fine algorithm
so this is a very powerful way if you
can put in enough constraints from your
working of the algorithm you can
actually derive analytically the
approximation algorithm of of a of an
algorithm without actually
combinatorially deriving the
approximation algorithm for a completely
combinatorial algorithm which was in our
case Facility Location okay so that was
this and the larger theme of course here
which you are all aware of is these
super great markets on the internet that
have given rise to completely new ways
of doing economics and these have taken
over our economy by the neck many of
these are trillion-dollar companies or
close to clear trillion dollars and some
of them are getting there such as cloud
computing and each one has a incentive
questions like the one that our friend
asked or other questions as well as
algorithmic questions and so there is a
huge amount of possibility of doing very
clear to work here and having big impact
that's it yeah so where everyone has
different budgets is it still possible
today oh yeah yeah that is this is the
main case the other thing is a simple
addition to this case the home yeah yeah
different bids not just 0 or epsilon
dollars and different budgets and yeah
mm-hmm and many other I mean you can
also add in extra things like the you
you have case lots rather than one you
have click-through rates and taken into
consideration you have you don't
necessarily charge the bit but that's
next highest bid all of those can be
either with small heuristics or directly
with rigorous analysis they have done
all of those things I mean there are
like a hundred papers there when I
mentioned algorithmic work it's a mini
industry started with this because it
was all relevant to these heavy-duty
multi-billion dollar markets so there
are many many things got done some some
totally relevant totally some relevant
into the future somewhere yes sir
as too much I am not aware of a worst
case analysis for that but I don't know
that even good google allows you to
enter and exit during the day I don't
know if they allow you to revise your
[ __ ] they must I mean or do they lose
right that's the reason they go for a
victory kind of thing so that people
don't trash around looking for the right
bid quote unquote
and this was happening before they did
the Wickery kind of thing where you pay
the next tile bid but with that you know
you are sealed off from from having to
pay your you make money in the stock
market if they don't make revenue we
want to cure that right we want to help
you with that you know these gaming
issues are very central to this whole
all these markets
that's why algorithmic game theory is
such a big player in all of this stuff
and there's a lot and lot and lot of
work on those exactly these questions
there they have been thought about to
then I don't know 50 levels you know so
I'm sure we can find III I have looked
into some of them I have worked on some
of them but I am NOT up to date with all
of them at this point but a small search
will tell you answers to most of your
questions I think
so thank you yes sir
how realistic is the assumption that the
distribution of EFT queries is unknown I
mean yeah so indeed and that was one of
her open problems it was solved by the
vendor and Hayes they gave a little o of
one so better than one minus one over e
if you if the queries come from a
distribution but you cannot entirely
rely on that because there are up and
down events all the time which take you
into the worst case so you want
something that's good from when you f
queries come from a distribution and
also whenever you switch into some
current event of the day which makes you
go into the worst case and and there are
even even approaches for that so a good
question but all dealt with I mean these
are you know worked out because there's
so much at stake you had a question yes
oh why is it the fraction of the budget
spent rather than say the amount of
budgetary mind because different people
have different because you you you you
want them all to finish to zero together
whether they have bid one dollar or two
hundred dollars I don't know it works if
you have a 1-1 already analysis for this
idea then that works also but I doubt it
yeah
yes sir extend to combinatorial bidding
at all oh well you can the bids are
combined for if I bit just for
co-occurrence of two keywords and the
other oh yeah
each keyword is is a set of words so you
can bid for for uh you mean like large
truths and small socks you know I I did
for someone who is who is looking for
CDs and books ah others only bid for
books oh no no no each person is bidding
for many keywords has a common budget
for all these keywords and maybe
different bits so you can even before as
this bitter one did he was bidding one
dollar for this and one dollar for this
but he could bid one dollar for this and
fifty cents for this yeah and meaning
somebody says books and CDs I'm sure
they'll get this query as well as that
query yeah or I don't know what Google
does but surely that comes into the and
is just thrown out and you becomes book
in 3d I think yeah I believe yeah yeah
so Google I think but Google does the
right thing always
[Laughter]
anything else so thank you so much and
thank you for coming
[Applause]